rockets are magnificent engineering
feats that have allowed us to travel
into space and orbit over the past
several decades
but though rockets are extremely cool
they cost massive amounts of money
and carry substantial risk during each
flight in contrast
we have our other flying masterpiece the
airplane not only can
airplanes also fly but they're
astronomically cheaper
and more reliable than rockets in fact
the annual risk of an american being
killed in an airplane crash
is only 1 in 11 million to put that into
perspective
nasa estimates that there is a 1 in 276
chance
of a falcon 9 disaster leading to loss
of life
that means that one of the most reliable
rockets of all time
is still 40 000 times riskier than your
average plane
but let's be real here i'm sure the
brainiacs working at space agencies
around the world
have already considered this so why
haven't we created planes that can just
fly into space well to answer this
question
we have to first understand the physics
behind how airplanes fly in the first
place
while it may seem like the powerful
engines on airplanes are doing all the
work and keeping us
airborne this is actually not true
in fact the engines on airplanes are
quite weak in comparison to the maximum
capacity
of the plane the ratio between the force
generated by a plane's engines and the
gravitational force pulling down the
airplane
is called the thrust to weight ratio and
you'll be surprised to hear how low
these ratios really are
the boeing 747-8 only has a
thrust-to-weight ratio of
0.269 and the largest passenger aircraft
the airbus a380
only has a thrust-to-weight ratio of
0.227
the thrust-to-weight ratios of most
commercial aircraft land between 0.2 and
0.35
even the concorde which was a supersonic
commercial aircraft
only has a thrust to weight ratio of
0.372
but if airplane engines are only
generating enough thrust to lift a fifth
to a third of the plane's maximum weight
how is the plane even able to gain
altitude well
this is where extremely clever
engineering of the wings comes into play
the underside of an airplane's wings are
flat while the top side of the
airplane's wings are rounded
this means that the air flowing on the
top side of the wing has to travel a
further distance
than the air on the bottom side of the
wing the total volume of air flowing on
either side of the wing however
is the same so the air on the top side
of the wing
is spread over a larger area than the
air on the bottom side of the wing
this difference causes the top side of
the wing to have a lower pressure than
the bottom side of the wing
given that particles naturally want to
move from high pressure to low pressure
the wing naturally wants to move upwards
and this force is called lift
if we're able to create a large enough
pressure difference between the two
sides of the wings
the generated lift will be greater than
the gravitational force pulling down the
airplane
and that's the secret behind how
airplanes actually gain altitude
over the past several decades engineers
have basically perfected
every single component of the plane from
bending the tips of the wings to
utilizing flaps
all of these efforts have one goal in
mind maximize lift and to minimize fuel
consumption
while this has made airplanes insanely
efficient it has also made them
extremely dependent on air
without air most of our planes wouldn't
leave the ground
but what if we just put more powerful
engines onto our planes
or made their planes themselves smaller
if we could get the thruster weight
ratio to be greater than one
airplanes wouldn't need lift to gain
altitude right
well that is true and we actually have a
bunch of fighter jets that do have a
thrust to weight ratio that's greater
than one
the f-15 for instance has a ratio of
1.04
and the f-22 has a ratio of 1.09 which
can even be increased to 1.26 with the
right combination of fuel and payload
this is why these jets can do vertical
takeoffs loops
barrel rolls and who knows what else but
just because these jets are not
dependent on lift does not mean that
they are not dependent
on air and that brings me into the
fundamental difference between rocket
engines and jet engines
both engines use combustion and use
their law to move forward
but if you think about it you'd quickly
realize that a jet engine has both an
intake and an exhaust
while rocket engines only have an
exhaust jet engines have an intake
because they rely on the oxygen in the
air for combustion
without a steady intake of oxygen
combustion can't take place
and the jet engines simply won't work
now it's not like rocket engines are
any better rocket engines also need
oxygen to work
and this is why we have solid and liquid
rocket propellant
in a solid fuel rocket the fuel and
oxidizers mix together into a chemical
an engine simply use a chemical during
flight with liquid fuel rockets the fuel
and the oxidizer are actually stored
separately
and the engines combine the two
ingredients during combustion
but either way both the jet and rocket
engines need oxygen to operate
and since jets don't carry oxygen along
with them they can't just fly into space
so the bottom line is basically just a
lack of atmosphere
in space planes need the atmosphere to
generate a lift and they need an auction
in the atmosphere to fire up their
engines
if the atmosphere didn't thin out as we
reach space planes should theoretically
be able to fly anywhere in the solar
system
though it would be a rather slow mode of
transportation
but since that's not the case airplanes
generally have a surface ceiling
which is generally around 42 to 43 000
feet
what if we just dropped rocket engines
to airplanes though as long as the
thrust weight ratio is greater than one
the aircraft would no longer be
dependent on the atmosphere
people have actually had this idea for
nearly 100 years at this point
with the first rocket-powered flight
dating back to early 1900s
in 1928 a german plane called the
lipente
became the first aircraft to fly using
rocket power a couple of years later in
an italian aviator named ito cottoneo
built their first privately built rocket
plane we also saw several rocket-powered
aircraft throughout world war
ii but it wasn't until the cold war that
we actually tried to use this technology
to reach space the most notable space
plane attempt of all time
was likely the north american x-15 the
x-15 was proposed
way back in december of 1954 which was
before nasa even existed
so the plane was to be built by north
american aviation and reaction motors
the plan was to carry the x-15 on a
mother ship called the b-52
to an altitude of 8.5 miles at a speed
of 500 miles per hour
at this point the b-52 would release the
x-15
and the x-15 would use two liquid
propellant rocket engines to fly
as high as possible fortunately the x-15
actually made it past the concept board
and the first rocket power flight would
take place on september 17
1959 over the next decade the various
versions of the x-15 would be flown 199
times
fun fact one of the pilots of the x-15
was neil armstrong
anyway in 1963 pilot joe walker would
successfully fly the plane past 100
kilometers in altitude
which meant that the x-15 could
officially reach space
but aside from technically reaching
space the x-15 couldn't actually
complete anything meaningful
in space it couldn't reach orbit and
there was nowhere near escape velocity
of mach 33
but nonetheless the plane was extremely
impressive as it could reach mach 6
or 4 000 miles per hour and it was a
great first step in developing a plane
that could actually travel into space
after the x-15 program came to a close
nasa decided to basically develop a
hybrid space plane with the space
shuttle
the idea was to launch like a rocket but
land like a plane
but this is when nasa would run into by
far the largest obstacle when it comes
to space planes
and that's excessive heat though the
x-15 was an extremely fast aircraft
it could only reach one-fifth the speed
of escape velocity speeding up the
aircraft to escape velocity itself
was extremely difficult but that wasn't
the main obstacle
the main problem was that it was and
still is nearly impossible to handle the
generated heat
but wait a minute we have rockets that
go way faster than the x-15
so how are they able to handle the heat
well that's the reason that rockets
launch vertically
at least at the beginning the idea is to
get the rocket as high as possible
before it reaches extreme velocities
at these higher altitudes the atmosphere
will be much thinner which heavily
reduces the generated heat
the easy solution to this problem would
be to just launch the space plane
vertically
and that's basically what nasa settled
on with the space shuttle
at that point it's more of a rocket than
a space plane
but even after doing this nasa faced
major heat problems when it came to
re-entry
the underside of the space shuttle had a
total of 20 548 heat shield towers
and every single tile had to be
individually inspected after every
single flight
even a small amount of damage to these
heat shield tiles could lead to
catastrophic results like we saw with
colombia
so truthfully nasa never figured out an
efficient way to re-fly the space
shuttle
and this was one of the biggest
downfalls of the space shuttle
considering this nasa should have never
tried to make a full-on space plane
until they figured out a more efficient
solution for the space shuttle but
nonetheless nasa started to work on a
single stage to orbit space plane called
the x30 in the 1980s
the plane was slated to have top speeds
of mach 25
and it seemed like the plane would be
straight out of a movie this should have
been a major red flag though as the
plane was way too over ambitious
according to nasa engineer ivan becky
the x30 was the biggest window
ever to be forced it on the country and
it was full of dubious aerodynamic
claims
and indian performance claims and
thermal claims basically
nasa had nowhere near enough technology
to make the plane a reality
and the 1.7 billion invested into the
project was a complete waste
nasa didn't give up after the x30 though
later on they started working on the x43
which did reach production and it was
able to achieve a top speed of mach 9.6
but even that isn't nearly enough to
reach orbit
in the meantime the overarching space
community has come to our broad
conclusion
what's even the point of trying to solve
this nearly impossible heat problem with
space planes
when we can just keep using traditional
rockets and continue exploring space
at the end of the day who cares if the
vehicle launches vertically
or horizontally the destination is what
really matters
though it would be super cool to fly a
plane into space it really doesn't pose
any additional benefits
originally many scientists thought that
space planes were the key to reusability
and cheap launch costs but spacex is
proving that these attributes can be
achieved using traditional rockets
so the excitement around space planes is
more or less dying off
maybe decades from now after we've
mastered traditional rockets
we'll see space planes make a comeback
but in the meantime
it makes no sense to try to battle with
the laws of physics when you can just
launch vertically
would you prefer to ride in a space
plane or a traditional rocket
comment that down below also drop a like
if you thought this video explained the
physical limitations of space may as
well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one